alors alors tu veux toujours pas vous ai
un je veux toujours pas jouer ça tu
abuses de passer une troisième nuit au
violent 1
ça m'amuse pas monsieur respecteur moi
je préfère le jouer de la guitare mais
tu te fous de moi fois tu te fous de moi
ça fait trois nuits comprises comme ça
de moi sa vertu si tu veux jouer les
imbéciles en bas 2 et à ce jeu je suis
imbattable mais j'en suis sûr specter a
tu veux faire le marché tu veux faire un
mario saint amand n'y a pas la mer dit
pas mais personne ici est averti alors
on repart tout du début du commencement
nom prénom situation de famille adresse
et tout le toutim vallée nom le prénom
amérique au maintien
j'ai dix noms et prénoms j'ai pas dis
prénom et nom macias en ricochet ce à
quoi je me mêle plus prétentieux des
prétentieux alors moi je serai alors
robert castel alors pourquoi pas
pas aussi bon c'est quoi si toi aussi
bon que vous aussi bon que vous si moi
je dois aussi beaucoup tentative de
corruption par la flatterie tu vas tu
sais que ça peut te coûter cher ça tu
sais saint titienne pour dix ans alors
que vous êtes beaucoup plus vilain que
lui de quoi la sultane inspecteurs
assermentés kabila kabange alors s'avère
qui a ça peut te coûter cher st tu as
compris j'en ai marre j'en ai marre mois
sait plus quoi vous dire à la fin vous
et moi je veux je te dit tout mettre à
table
si vous voulez que je me mette à table
arrêté de me cuisiner comment je
pourrais croire monsieur fait de
l'esprit monsieur fêter ce prix alors on
n'est pas sorti de l'auberge en question
bon alors ne me parlez plus jeunes ils
ont construit jamais voté au bon c'est
vrai tu vas tu es maintenant tu vas me
dire où cheney en algérie at elle ou non
muté alors comment ça commence à faire
pas l'accent pied n'ont alors pas le
moine raconte a fait ça que je suis mon
raisonnement est de la cij avait
l'accent peu noir si tu avais l'accent
blé noir ça devrait choquer avec moi
puisque moi je n'ai pas du tout et alors
on a le même marchand tous les deux donc
ça pas l'accent pieds-noirs cqfd allez
allez qu'est-ce que vous avez l'oreille
musicale monsieur l'inspecteur de vidéo
tu vas mettre une sourdine un peu ouais
bon maintenant tu vas me dire qu'est ce
que c'est que cette feuille qu'on a
trouvées sur toi avec plein d'élan
mentalités alors qu'est ce que c'est que
sa taille c'est un rendez vous avec des
amis rené vous pourquoi le rendez-vous
pourquoi pour passer de la semoule en
contrebande par exemple pourquoi ces
débits style par la suisse 1 qu'elle
distille quelques autres bandes qu'elles
se moule
moi je suis au régime wade
c'est des amis je sais pas moi deux des
camarades et des artistes du service et
vous vous avez gagné ici je m'allonge
enfin je m'allonge vais tout vous dire
l'anc est marqué les marges avaient
alors qu'ici que ces lentilles cela j'ai
rendez vous avec les ritchie family
works et jane manson barque et elisabeth
jérôme marqué et yves simon oui un
groupe de gitans voilà los reyes a et
tout de suite les arrière pensées
allaient à la loge pour la vida badman
michel sardou jean claude rich et son
orchestre oui il ya même 4 qui mot de
passe
hélas au qanoun way et puis akalé oui
oui il ya même mon père alors même mon
père je les balances et emballant qu'est
ce que c'est que c'est un un réseau
international cette histoire de semoule
alors mais c'est pas possible
mais qui exercent une pression sur ces
gens tu les fais chanter par un moyen
quelconque qu'est ce que c'est
c'est pas du chantage enfin nous on aime
la musique nous tout simplement
c'est trop d'arrière-pensées monsieur
l'inspecteur de moi mais moi j'aime la
musique c'est ça je chante moi vous
savez vous savez pas s'il a dit cela
mais je sens drew brees bourg de la
musique c'est tout